let's go next to our caller from the
four
zero four area code who's calling today
from four
zero four
four zero four it seems like you may
have us muted
hi david yes
yes yo you can hear me i can who's this
oh this is connor how are you sir connor
pleasure to hear from you
okay uh ditto um so i want to ask david
uh
i have a quick question then i have an
opinion i want to hear your thoughts on
okay uh the first quick question g um i
i've seen you on a couple
um shows uh say uh jesse lee petersons
um well really that's the only one
really and i i i did
watch a little bit of when you were on
joe rogan but um
i've heard you say that you're not a
democrat
and that you're i know you're i know
you're not a conservative but i've heard
you say you're not a democrat but you i
know you
uh most uh for the most part you usually
use the word progressive
what would you definitively state
yourself as
so connor i want to make sure i'll
answer but
i you're not conflating political party
and political ideology right because
when you say conservative or democrat
democrat is a political party
conservative is an ideology so i want to
make sure we're not
it's i want to make sure you're not
confused about what you're asking
i'm sorry yeah i know um republican or
democrat conservative i shouldn't have
used conservatives
okay um so so here's the deal i am not
a democrat because for me the democratic
party
is another institution that i don't find
it particularly useful
to associate with in any formal way or
to pledge any kind of loyalty
or whatever it's never been clear to me
why i would register as a democrat
in modern politics my views of social
democracy which is how i identify
are more represented by
candidates in the democratic party than
candidates in the republican party
but that could change and so the way i
characterize my views is
i am a progressive social democrat
in practice i'm mostly voting for
democratic candidates
but i've never found any particular in
massachusetts i can still vote in
whichever primary
i want i've never lost anything by not
being a registered democrat and i just
don't feel particularly drawn to be one
okay amazing um i uh i'm just curious
because i i've never heard you at least
from what i've seen from you i've never
heard you state definitively what you
are
um i would consider myself i would say
i'm more in the middle probably
um i try to be as open-minded as
possible listen to
all sides and all spectrums but um
anyways
uh my opinion i want to get to so i am
biracial i'm also 19 so it's going to be
the first year which i can vote and i
don't know how
i don't know how much you talk about on
your show i don't know how much to talk
about race relations
but um being biracial i am black and
white
uh growing up in the south i'm from uh
atlanta georgia
i went to predominantly black schools
for the most part i went to a
predominantly black middle school
predominantly back high school and i'm
taking
college courses online so it's not
really um i don't really go anywhere and
see people but
um i want to ask i just want your
opinion on it because
growing up in these areas that are
predominantly black
um i've been treated certain ways and a
lot of people call it colorism
um i've been treating treated certain
ways because i am
lighter skinned uh some people look at
me they're like oh you're black or oh
you're
white or oh you're hispanic um and it
never offends me i just you know i get
i'm
a little ambiguous looking uh but it's
uh
um i've noticed i've been treating i've
been treated a certain way by
uh a lot of um
african-americans in this in the area i
live in i've been uh i've been called
a white boy which isn't really a
derogatory term but
i've been called white boy i've been
called uh cracker i've been assumed
because i don't uh um because i don't
align myself with a lot of political
parties i've been assumed to be
a nazi or a uh
a white supremacist um things like that
and it was just
it's so silly and i don't really call it
ignorance and the reason why i don't
call it ignorance
this is one thing i actually kind of
agree with jessie lee peterson on
because he told me he said it
it's not really ignorance it's more so
that's how they're being brought up
and that's what they're being taught to
believe right is
um um by their parents or whoever you
know whatever talking head you know
that might spew the type of things that
they believe in but um
i've just noticed that it's it's very
common you know
and and it's it's proof that it has it
doesn't only have anything to do with
just
me going to school because i've
experienced it at work i've experienced
that
i've experienced it outside of work like
you know in social
settings and things like that and uh
i've had people
countless times try to diminish
my experience say oh you wouldn't
understand what it's like being black or
you wouldn't like all that other
nonsense and i just i feel like it's
kind of ridiculous because i i don't
really think that the reason why
black people are black people who dream
like that i don't think it has anything
to do with
say systemic racism or because we're
holding them down i just think it has to
do with the
the um immorality or the just the lack
of respect for other people
so i kind of want your take on that yeah
i mean i i tend to agree with you now my
experience with this obviously
is not personal it's more academic and
through talking to others but colorism
is
prevalent all over the world in
different ways in different places
i would defer to you if you're telling
me that
you don't identify that that's happening
because of reasons a and b
and it's happening because of reason c
and d i think your experience in in that
is important
and it certainly passes the sniff test
for me it sounds plausible
that the reason you are called what
you're called because
you don't look as black as some of the
people around you
i don't think that that is directly
because of systemic racism
and and i i i think your assessment on
it is way better than any
any i could give
okay well i appreciate that david all
right i appreciate the call thank you so
much great to hear from you glad
we were able to take a few phone calls
we turned a bad situation
a call a guest canceling last minute
into a good situation because i was able
to hear
from a few of you we will go to a break
and have much more
right after this